Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to Do or Die. Now this is a "quiz game"?
I'm not a hundred percent sure about what it is but it has.. oh hi
hi okay, that's weird. Oh
"Shut the annoying guy up"
Who's the annoying guy? Oh, okay? All right? I win? I don't know what happened
I don't know why. Hide the fart? What am I doing? Why is there a guy shootin' a robo?
What oh excuse me why are you doing this to anybody? Oh, God?
That didn`t hide it! Everybody could see it! When you make a fart cloud that's visible on the visible spectrum, people are gonna see it!
Oh, there's a cow in your eye why. Yeah. God that was horrifying. Why was that even a thing? Flip the table?!
I'm gonna flip the table in rage because I don't even know what this game is about. Oh
Oh shit. Sorry Aliens. Oh that's a bad boding well boo for the alien, human- I don't even
Fucking bicep mushroom cloud? Smash the bug? I don't know this is appealing my ADD, but I have no idea, oh boy
this seems like a bad idea. this seems like a
whoo
I don't think that would have protected from hitting the casing at all
I think it would've blown everything up. Also that's obviously a robo of love. What is the square root of... uh
Huh?
Rawr! (Totally Correct)
Yay, do nothing
Okay, alright. I'm doing nothing. Yay
This is exactly like that other game "The Easy-est Game." This is not the easiest game. You don't know what you're doing. Shoot the kite.
Whaaaaat? I very clearly- Eat? Eat that's it? I just gotta eat?
Oh, you just got those out of your eye
Oh gross
Okay, whoa. I did it. New games unlock free the Chupacabra
high five the pirate I don't understand any of this
I seem to be a little lost in the why of the department that I'm in. Can someone please call a manager?
I seem to be just lost. Alright hang on let's go back, alright.
Story
Okay?
Excuse you?? Where'd you- Why is there a goat? I never thought I'd have to shout that question out into the- oh. Chuck Huck.
(Confused Markiplier Noises) Who's Chuck Huck??
Oh It's the same thing oh, it's the exact same
I didn't read it last time because- hide your fart, okay
Chase the goat with your wig and hide the fart I know how this works
Okay good. I did that. Clear th- I've done this. I've dood it. Oh, God it's a rhino this time.
Yeah, free the Chupacabra this is a new one
habang
How is that good?? with thaaaaaat?
A business man??
Dude, uh oh, oh, I thought that was gonna be armageddon up in my butt. (What?)
Everyone cheers and makes more noise, and causes more disturbance and then everyone gets popcorn thrown at their head and dies.
I'm gonna do something. Oh fuck. God. Oh. God. No. I'm sorry (R.I.P Happy Dude)
I didn't know that that would happen if I did something. I apologize. All right I'ma shoot this kite ruin some kids day. Doo doo doo
Oh here we go
Yep, how did I predict that was gonna happen I ruin a kid's day
That's fucking gross. Oh my God. I know that's gonna be the thumbnail oh, God
Maybe that's also a contender. Don't get crushed and pet the cat. Okay. There's also, options? Eh who cares about that
there's also endless mode here, and I don't know ooh
A Pirate
Leprechaun I think a cat
Okay, high five the pirate. All right?
Oh, what would happen if I'd gotten hooked? Why do I got to do this again?
Oh God, no our secret high five is ruined
So stupid
this is so stupid I love it
Let me give him another high-five
oh
It's Captain five beard over here. He needs high fives to keep him alive. The curse of the blahdebluh and the brimnumnuh and the
Flippity flapping, it's the same Pattern. Why am I just high-fiving this pirate over and over again?
I you think that I would have something better to do but no I don't I have nothing better to do my life is a
Sham
I just do this. I high five pirates all day every day and
Everything's good in my life because that's how I get joy. The only way I can get joy anymore. Oh, you're going fast now. Oh
Yeah, oh you think you can go faster than MEAAA oh, no?
Stupid idiot. Think you can go fast. You ain't sonic bitch, you don't go fast you go slow
Oh shit
All of my, bravado is now wasted. Quit to menu let's see what the leprechaun- don't get crushed. All right?
Okay, let's do this. Oh no poor jacksepticeye. Oh no, what will happen? OH GOD HE`S DEAD! XD
oh, no, oh
Alright I'll save you this time I'll save- Jack run. Look out. There's blocks falling on Ireland. Oh. God no
He's alive everybody (yay!)
Alright here's uh, whatever this is. Pet the cat. Okay. Cool sure yeah, let's do this one
This doesn't look like I'm about to pet the- okay. I don't think that was a pet. That was a stranglers grasp
That was a baby crusher grip there, and I know. I've crushed many babies. I didn't mean to do that cookie
I'm gonna figure out how to lose this one.
(Markiplier Noises)
Okay just no losing that. Im'a not pet it
I'm gonna make a concerted effort to not pet this cat. Eat dicks cat. Little cookie bitch. Who stole the cookie from the cookie jar
Holy shit
I'm sorry
I didn't know that that was gonna happen if I had anticipated that I would have taken measures to it avert that
I'm gonna- I'm going to. I'm going to. I'm- oo hi ok Thom- Thomas the trank trengine
Looks like Thomas might'a had a little too much acid. Oh boy. Is that a Flappy Boird
Chuck Huck
I don't like Chuckin' Huck
Alright, I chucked Huck. Oh. God this one again. Oh, there's a ninja in your eye
Why is there a ninja in your eye? Pet the cat? Oh, I- I'm a- I'm a, I'm an expert at petting the cat
I know all about petting the cat. Free the Chup and kill the lovely family. It was just over the break
They're dead now. That guy got punched to death.
Free the Chupa- I just did this
You know you think in my eternal wisdom I would realize this is a bad idea but ok. He's dead now that guy's dead
Free the Chupacabra oh good. Oh third time's a charm. Maybe I should learn from my mistakes and not free this bastard
Oh well, there he goes your husband's dead again. You came back from oh
boy
Why is it just chupacabra? Maybe I'm not supposed to free the Chupacabra
Let me just let that simmer on the oven for a few more minutes
Yeah, okay, I lost
It's just stuck. Alright here we go again. We're back onto the freein' the Chupacabra. Let's see if it works this time
Haboink. I did it. I won. Oh good I move on. gross.
Aw I missed my mouth. How did I do that? I'm an asshole. Oh
So sorry kid I'm so sorry had to be done gotta get more minigames. I'm addicted. Don't get crushed.
Don't truck- crush JackSepticEye. Oh, don't let him get crushed. Oh, God. He's gonna- okay he's alright
Okay, that robo is dead now, I guess. Dress the cupcake, trim the nose hairs.
Boy those sound like great games that I want to play here we go
Dress the cupcake. Great
There we go. There we go. There we go.
Why does it need a straw? What is this? Oh.
You were happy and then you died. Okay, I think that's a sadistic ending to this game. Oh, no
Let's not do that again. Ugh some kind of ritual sacrifice because this next one says "oh, oh woe is me"
Oh, woe is me? And woe is be. What a world that
It would have been if I had been able to play the game pluck the nose hairs. Oh, what a fantabulous day
That would have been if I had been able to do that, but its mobile only
Well, I guess I'm just bowin around until the end of time, so I won't be able to do that
What a bag of douchetry- eh it's pretty good as cynical as I was about what the hell was going on in there
I had a lot of fun with it. I always loved mini game games. I always loved little flash mini game games
They're always fun, but why you gotta hold things on mobile only I'm not going to download this app
No way, so either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below and as always I will see you
In the next video bye. Buh Bye!